Kevin Feige and his merry band of Marvel movie-makers
brought down the house at San Diego Comic-Con
2019.
To a sea of buzzing fans, Marvel Studios announced
a shining slate of Phase 4 movies and television
series set to launch over the next two years
everything from the Jane Foster-featuring
Thor: Love and Thunder to a Shang-Chi movie,
to a bunch of Disney+ superhero shows.
What was missing from the jam-packed panel,
though, was the announcement of another Avengers
movie which some fans were holding out hope
for, thanks to past rumors that suggested
Marvel was cooking up a fifth ensemble film
featuring Earth's Mightiest Heroes.
In the aftermath of Marvel's presentation,
studio president Feige revealed to IGN the
reason why Avengers 5 wasn't announced at
San Diego Comic-Con.
Simply put, it's because there will be no
Avengers 5, as far as Feige is concerned.
The era of Avengers films as we know them
concluded with Avengers: Endgame, Feige explained,
and it's now time for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe to move on to new superhero stories.
It isn't necessarily out with the old, but
it's certainly in with the new when it comes
to Phase 4 of the MCU.
Feige explained:
"We had a movie this year called Avengers:
Endgame, and it is very much an ending, as
you saw, to so many of those characters.
So Phase 4 is about beginnings, and Phase
4 is about learning new things about characters
you already think you know like Black Widow,
meeting incredible new characters like The
Eternals and Shang-Chi, going on new adventures
with Doctor Strange and Thor, and these Disney+
shows, which I promise will be spectacular
and not what anybody's expecting."
Feige isn't saying that the past needs to
die and that Marvel should never acknowledge
the Avengers again, but it's clear he wants
Marvel fans to understand that the new chapter
of the MCU is meant to be just that: new.
Though it's not easy to let go and say goodbye
to heroes you've watched evolve for years,
and while it will take some time for everyone
to fully recover from the events of Avengers:
Endgame, there's really nothing to do but
give in to change right?
"Dread it.
Run from it.
Destiny arrives all the same.
And now it's here."
OK, well, uhh… maybe that guy's not the
best guy to take philosophical advice from.
Anyway, Earth's Mightiest Heroes very well
might round up again but it won't happen in
Phase 4.
And the potential ensemble flick will feature
a different roster, likely a blend of older
Marvel mainstays and fresh faces introduced
in Phase 4 and the to-be-announced Phase 5.
Longtime Marvel star Samuel L. Jackson is
confident of this possibility, and believes
that his character, Nick Fury, will round
up the villain-fighting forces in the future.
Asked by CinemaBlend if he thinks that Avengers-centric
movies should be "shelved" in favor of team-up
films like Spider-Man: Far From Home, which
brought Fury and new MCU character Mysterio
into Spidey's solo series, Jackson said he
doesn't agree.
He elaborated, saying that Fury knows a threat
is headed to Earth, and that he'll eventually
need to create a new crew of Avengers to defeat
the imminent danger.
"I always think that there's room for every
kind of story to be told.
And at some point, they're going to have to
put together another Avengers group of some
sorts to deal with whatever's coming next.
Nick [Fury] knows something is coming, the
same way he found out in Captain Marvel that
there are other things that need to be dealt
with that [he] didn't know about.
This is moving us to another place."
So, could we get a Young Avengers movie?
Maybe!
Perhaps a Dark Avengers film?
Yeah, why not?
But a fifth Avengers flick with the OG Thor
and Cap, Iron Man and Black Widow, Hawkeye
and Hulk?
Well… don't hold your breath.
Unless you're Nick Fury.
You never tell Nick Fury he's wrong…
"We get into a situation like this again,
what happens then?"
"They'll come back."
"You really sure about that?"
"I am."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.